we know the pandemic has hit the movie
industry really hard now washington's
sending money to help the marquees
open and stay on movie theaters have sat
mostly empty
for almost a year revenue for the
industry dropped 80 percent in 2020
putting many feeders sadly big and small
on the brink of bankruptcy
some theaters have tried to attract
customers by renting private screenings
but the business is now competing
heavily with streaming services
over 80 percent of the movies that were
supposed to be shown this year have been
delayed
some of those have gone direct to
streaming the national association of
theater owners helped successfully lobby
congress for 15 billion dollars
businesses that can qualify can use it
to pay employees
rent utilities the money expected to be
available by the spring at the earliest
we reached out to you on twitter movie
theaters are struggling do you think
that the
future of movie watching has changed or
do you think movie theaters will bounce
back it's a split
half of you 50 say yes streaming is the
future
the other half saying nope i want to go
back get my popcorn seat on the big
screen theaters will rebound ted stands
in that category i guarantee it